let's jump to the story from Jalopnik
Elon Musk once again kicks off pride
month with transphobia boosting
transphobic documentary is one hell of a
way to start June and uh they're
basically complaining because they're
leftists that Elon Musk tweeted out it's
he said every parent should watch this
it's the daily wires tweet it's the
movie they said they really don't want
you to see what is a woman take a look
at this Let me refresh actually Elon
musk's tweet currently has
53.6 million views crazy and the daily
wire has 80.5 million views wow I don't
think those numbers are overlapped
they're not unique users between the two
of them so it it may be different
but
Elon Musk not only de-censored the daily
wise documentary but he's actively
promoting it on his page and I think he
he pinned it let me make sure yeah yeah
he did well so he defend it it's not
enough to
um not watch what is a woman you have to
be actively in favor of promoting what
is a woman if you want to be an ally I
thought he did censor it he did Twitter
Twitter
and now Ella Irwin was I think you guys
spoke about this last night but she
resigned and another person had a trust
and safety and we were we were talking
about this earlier I can't remember who
said it I don't know if it was one of
you guys that he probably went to them
and said you can resign now or I will
fire you and they said then I resign
because that doesn't make sense why they
would resign it's it's interesting to me
that that Ella had such a I think you
were actually tweeting about this
yesterday that she had such a positive
relationship with some of the right-wing
people that were getting unbanned over
the past six months or so
um but it definitely seems to me that
there was some sort of a civil war
within Twitter where she was like we're
not We're not gonna allow this to be
seen and Elon was like well then you're
gone but I think it's still not out if
you don't subscribe to daily wire it's
not going to show up in your
recommendations and no ads will play on
it this is what I tweeted out yesterday
no I think I think you removed that I
think he changed it also really doesn't
matter that much because everybody that
I've seen quote tweeting it or embedding
the video I've seen on the for you page
and I think it came out Elon responded
to one of them someone was promoting his
Tweet someone was paying to promote his
tweet it could be it could be that Elon
was warned by a bunch of these
governments if you don't restrict it we
will take some action against you and so
he found a very clever way to say FU by
okay it is going to be not recommended
otherwise we get banned then he tweets
it out then he promotes it then someone
promotes his tweet and he says now
everyone who follows me will see it yeah
that's a good point yeah it was
disheartening to see so many people
coming at him right out of the gate
because at the Babylon B we had just
released our interview with him and he
really emphasized his commitment to free
speech there and he said there's so many
people swimming in the woke Kool-Aid is
what he said he's really emphasized his
mission against all of this wolf crap I
think he called it the lgbtq Anon Circle
did he actually say that yeah wow right
didn't he say he said recently that he
didn't like the word woke or something
like that
I really don't like how this all went
down with the daily wire they were like
Elon please you're supposed to can we
please have our Free Speech please can
we have it like you don't have to ask
for that you that is God's given right
well hold on
I don't I don't agree with that I think
that the daily wire
and many people
unfairly attacked Elon
and I I said we'll wait and see if it
gets restored and if it doesn't I will
just I will end our Enterprise
subscription here's the point here's the
point
Elon Musk was not here he was in
Shanghai yes he's probably sleeping
right he wakes up and his phone's going
forward and he's like why is everyone
yelling at me I didn't do anything and
then he opens up and they're like Elon
betrayed us he was supposed to be for
free speech and then he's like I'm gonna
fix it it'll be done dear God then he
has to go and slack and say who can
change this who's responsible for it
then he's dealing with meetings that
he's dealing with people and they're
like why isn't he doing it now and then
he finally does fix it and reverse it
and one UPS it by promoting it himself I
think he's gonna above and beyond and
it's ended up being a massive win for
daily wire but my point of contention
was too that Jeremy was and no hate to
daily wire but you know Jeremy was going
on Spaces saying that he heard it was
this very convoluted game of telephone
he said that he heard that Elon Musk was
in the room when the decision was made
to censor the video which was patently
absurd because as you said he was in
China there's no way he could have been
in the room and Ella Erwin who is head
of trust and safety I'm pretty sure
she's Seattle based so it could have
been digital room yeah
so I don't think he was in the room at
all I don't think he was but I I do
think that there's a reason for concern
because if Elon is going to delegate any
of these decision making and bring on
this new CEO which is wef tied well then
we have reason to be concerned because
he continues to give lip service to
being completely uncensored but yet he
brings in people that are not seeing the
world how he does I got it
I figured it out lay it on me Elon Musk
should consult with the mises caucus
thank you I'm not joking yeah he should
he should say he should reach out to
mises caucus people to ask them who that
they could who they could hire to do
internal Audits and review that'd be
amazing because I think the libertarian
someone uh you don't think so no I think
don't do it Elon I think you're not
you're not putting a proposition you're
not putting a republican in there who's
gonna yeah piss off the left you're
getting someone who's not of either
party of a different party we just care
about Free Speech who's gonna be like
look we're we're for Free Speech but
then we're gonna be doing oversight to
make sure that people are allowed you
should never have to be like hey
Corporation can I have free speech
that's it's not a question you have to
ask a corporation this is being done
wrong the code should be available
people should be able to make their own
Twitter and access all this stuff
public I consider this public data but
it's elon's data it's private hey he
owns everything on Twitter right now he
can shut it all down right now to my
tomorrow you can do it right now he
should honestly let's go to Black
I'm going to press delete sorry you know
I'm just really tired of people tweeting
at me what were you saying that oh I was
gonna say I think it's helpful in the
regard that it probably sheds some light
on that they're still you know woke
people in Twitter that are doing the
bidding of the woke overlords yeah yeah
I mean that wasn't going to go all over
it look right A lot of people left but
you knew they were going to be someone
who stayed around just explain this to
me
I don't have kids okay but explain to me
how the left are more willing to
sacrifice for an idea than people on the
right are for their kids because they
don't have something to live for if you
really care about Humanity in life you
don't want to throw it away because the
left of revolution is yes
I mean they can also I don't know if
it's like the left gets to pick and
choose their sacrifices right like how
many of these left-wing streamers
literally live in multi-million dollar
Mansions they don't make actual
sacrifices for their values they'll do
things that make them comfortable and
then every now and again make a decision
that you know I just want to say because
about that what really bothers me is how
the left is substantially more
capitalist than I am and I'm a
capitalist and I'm like my actual house
is very small and very cheap and then
you get insert left a streamer
that's not actually ironic because
somebody on the right and this is not
true of everyone on the right in
conservatism is going through a massive
identity crisis right now but broadly
speaking what the right has represented
is a person growing in virtue and caring
for themselves and the people around
them and that includes the people who
work for you not not all conservatives
have done this not all capitalists have
done this but the left does not have a
similar value structure their value
structure is I impose my will on how you
should run your business not I build
something and then do good with it so
when he builds something because he's
trained himself to see himself as a
Perpetual victim he's going to find some
rationalization to buy himself nice
fancy things instead of giving his
workers more or helping the poor I love
his response where he was like
he was making fun of people saying
because you're a socialist you can't own
a house like oh man I'm like dude it's
not about the house it's about it's a
five million dollar house yeah or I
don't know how much it costs it was like
five million bucks right multi-million
dollar home multi-million dollar home in
Beverly Hills or something
your signaling is so superficial too
though and I've said this about
especially I think the black lives
matter protests especially the black
squares were so funny because it only
worked because it was aesthetically
pleasing if it was not a black square if
they said hey we're all gonna they've
seen their flag it's pretty awesome if
you told them to all post a picture of
George Floyd do you think they all would
have posted do you think millions of
people would have posted that they've
only that many people only posted a
black Square because it worked with the
Aesthetics of their feet and I'm telling
you that right now interesting they
would not have done it if it was not as
aesthetically pleasing and simple as a
black Square do you think so like I
don't know if the left is really in some
ways they're good with Aesthetics some
of them are but when you look at their
movement how it defines itself like
firstly these are the people who
Champion brutalism which is notoriously
ugly dedicated to making the public
squares ugly as possible and you look at
their flag like that's what the flag of
their regime is unbearably ugly it's
unbearably ugly and they all fly it 28
million people posted a black Square you
think 28 million people would have
posted a picture George Floyd depends
the one actually I agree I think they
would they wouldn't have it at all I
don't think so I think a million times
they would have posted a a like a mural
on a wall of George Floyd but they
wouldn't it would have been 28 million
you think Bella Hadid would have been
posting that absolutely not thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time